Hello.
[foreign language...]
Unless you know Hindi,
you wouldn't understand what I just said. What I
said was I wanted to tell you something very
important-- unless you know my language, you
can't understand it. All of you must know and must
have experienced LLMs (large language models) in
the recent times. Large language models are
very popularly known for generating text, but
it is also important to know that LLMs can also
do a very good job of translating languages. Why
is this important? It seems only about 25% of the
Internet users--their primary language is English.
And more than 65% of the users on the Internet
prefer to be provided information in their
primary languages--respective primary languages.
Also, more than 70% of Internet users would like
to receive support, issue resolution, etc. in
their preferred languages. Now, because they do
not receive the help in their primary languages,
more than 65% of these Internet users are using
machine translations to get the help that they
need. So it seems that machine translations are
essential for us to do business. So I'm going to
explain machine translations in two parts. First,
I will talk about how we have been doing machine
translation so far, and then I will jump to the
advantage of the large language models and how we
are going to do translations from them. So let's
see how machine translations are done. Machine
translations use artificial intelligence to
translate between languages automatically without
any human help. So how do they do that? Let's take
an example here: English, Spanish, and Japanese.
To translate between any of these languages,
you need linguistic rules and you need
dictionaries for each of these languages.
And the machine translation are done in multiple
approaches. The rule based approach--the rule
based approach is the one that predominantly
uses the linguistic rules and the dictionaries
and also the parallel dictionaries that have the
meanings of two different languages, the source
language as well as the target language. And then
we have the second approach called the statistical
approach. It takes a totally different approach
of leveraging the human translations and learning
the patterns from them and making very smart
guesses of those translations and delivering
those translations. Both approaches work very,
very well by the way. We take it one notch up
with the neural approach where, as in rule
based and statistical, it actually is looking
at each word to get to the translations. Neural
takes it one notch up because it is actually
looking at the sentence constructions to do the
translations. Now, as in any other approach,
you can take a combination of these approaches and
make it a hybrid approach. So as we discussed, the
traditional way makes use of the linguistic rules
as well as the dictionaries. And it goes through
the supervised learning into one. Large language
models do the translations differently. They make
use of the content that is already available in
different languages. We call it the large corpus
of parallel text. That is the examples of the same
text in different languages like English, Spanish,
Japanese and so on. And we feed it to the models.
So the large language models, as you all know,
use the transformer models and they have both the
encoder and decoder capabilities. On top of that,
the large languages models typically make use of
two approaches in doing the translations. Number
one is the sequence-to-sequence approach.
And the sequence-to-sequence approach,
you can take an input text and feed it to the
encoder. "Hello, how are you?" And the encoder
goes through the text and creates the semantic
representation of the text and also captures
the meaning of the text and passes it on to the
decoder. Now the decoder is capturing the semantic
representation and the meaning and translating
it to the representative target language. You
say "Hello, how are you?" in English, and if
your target language is going to be Spanish,
you will get "Hola, cómo estás". The second
approach-- also interesting --is the attention
model. The attention model is a little bit of a
lazy model compared to the sequence-to-sequence
one. The attention model is focusing on the
main relevant vocabulary of the sentence. It
is not going through the entire sentence. So
for example, it can pick up "hello" and "how
are you" and focus on the "hola" and "cómo
estás". But it is still going to capture the
meaning and the semantic representation essence
through the encoded and decoder. As you can see,
the larger language models, instead of using
the linguistic rules and the dictionaries are
really focusing on capturing the patterns and the
relationships between the data and translating it.
It's quite obvious now that everybody wants to be
communicated in their own language, including our
customers. Let's go leverage large language models
to meet them at the table and communicate in their
own language. Thank you for watching. Before
you leave, please click subscribe and like.